je reçois maintenant le cinéaste ettore
scola pour la sortie en salles de son
dernier film le dîner et or est un bon
soir alors je n'ai qu'un mot à vous dire
je vous ai tenté mais voilà merci nous
sommes tentés mais je le disais tout à
l'heure à mes amis a été je pense le
film qui m'a le plus marqué dans ma vie
parce que j'ai compris beaucoup de
choses sur la vie en voyant ce film et
je suis très heureux de vous recevoir
mais évidemment les explications étaient
déjà de la bossa
c'est humain peut aider oui elle m'a
aidé à comprendre beaucoup de choses sur
la vie notamment la compassion voilà
alors là vous venez pour votre dernier
film donc qui s'appelle le dîner avec
fanny ardant giancarlo giannini vittorio
gassman stefania sandrelli et marie
gillain
alors ça se passe dans un restaurant il
était de temps unité de lieu unité
d'action et on passe comme ça d'un
internaute un peu comme une symphonie
c'est un peu comme quand on dit des fois
j'aimerais être une mouche
c'est à dire que des fois quand on voit
des gens resteront visibles de quoi il
parle et là votre caméra passe d'une
table à l'autre est et cette curiosité
de savoir de deviner ce qu'on dise
une autre table et on le devine davis à
agen devine des gestes mais il ya sept
coups lui aussi fait c'est ça que j'ai
voulu aux deux personnages qui ont une
vision un peu plus globale c'est fanny
ardant que la patronne du restaurant et
vittorio gassman qui lui est un vieux
professeur on comprend bien qu'ils
mangent là tous les soirs
donc il a une position un peu arbitral
par rapport par rapport au reste
vous dites je viens du scénario et je
crois que l'écriture et la part la plus
importante du film c'est à dire que
finalement vous vous ai commencé comme
scénariste on aurait parlé et tout ce
qu'on voit là était écrit très
précisément parce que ça a l'air
tellement naturel tellement oui il faut
écrire tout pour avoir après même la
possibilité d'improviser
mais il faut avoir tous
ou décider à la basse on pourrait un
jour pour venir eu l'intuition
différentes alors rien n'est écrit dans
la pierre on peut changer mais si la
chose qui change entre dans
l'architecturé
[Musique]
alors on voit plusieurs personnages dont
ce sera la raconter il faut aller voir
le film mais bon y'a giancarlo giannini
qui avait que marie gillain alors lui
c'est un vieux professeur on est très
amoureuse de lui sait plus comment s'en
débarrasser parce qu'elle veut écrire à
sa femme et à ses fans à sandrelli qu'à
une fille qui veut devenir nonne il ya
une famille de bourgeois il ya un père
démissionnaire avec ses deux enfants
dont temps a été droguée on comprend
bien il ya une info mal et surtout
surtout une famille de japonais il ya
trois à poney le mari la femme et
l'enfant et y mettre du ketchup sur les
pattes et là on comprend à quel point
c'est terrible pour quelqu'un il faut
pas leur donner et fanny ardant
difficile client est roi et vous lui
donnez le ketchup et à la fin mais
faudrait pas terrible il faut comprendre
aussi les mixtures les compositions de
différentes cultures je pense que tous
les ceux qui viennent en europe vont
aussi enrichie de l'europe n'est pas
seulement apprendre un chose mais ils
amènent leur culture ils amènent
d'autres possibilités
l'addition finale appartiennent aux
jeunes aux petits dès qu'elles sont
orientale il amène sa fantaisie
voilà on peut raconter qu'ils regardent
le ciel à la fin du film et nous on voit
un ciel tout noir et lui ou un jeu vidéo
et c'est un signe vraiment c'est ça
termine très bien finir votre père était
médecin vous ai commencé à faire la
médecine qui après du droit est ce que
c'est parce que les études de droit et
est moins contraignante ou est ce que
c'est parce que vous avez des ambitions
politiques
donc je t'ai déjà je travaillais déjà
quand j'étais à l'université à dallas
un médecin ne me permettait pas oui
c'est plus la loi non c'était plus
facile
ils s'étaient rencontrés dans ces nasa
alors vous avez une histoire qui est
très célèbre sur vous si vous êtes très
tôt le goût des histoires parce que
votre grand père qui était à 28 il vous
faisait lire des histoires à briser pour
louis deux heures par jour et les mets
écouté et il aimait beaucoup surtout la
littérature françaises de l'histoire
française et donc je lisais un 9 ans des
choses qui ne comprenait pas du tout
montesquieu lamartine et napoléon pour
le vraiment rien de sainte hélène à 9
ans avait été extraordinaire mais
c'était sa passion est restée fracasse
oui et c'est la première fois que j'ai
connu que fera 15 c à travers la lecture
et mon grand-père et puis ça m'est
revenue après jusqu'à 192 avaient fait
le voyage du capitaine fracasse se
fracasser le premier que j'ai vraiment
compris quoi dans tous les bruits qui
vous quand on regarde votre vie on
s'aperçoit qu'effectivement bon nous on
a vu les films moi je vous connaissez
pas votre vie mais c'est vrai que une
journée particulière ce si beau film
avec sophie loren et marcello
mastroianni
vous avez vécu ça vous aviez quand
j'avais 7 1 le jour où tu es revenu ou
et j'étais la survie de rim perd on
s'appelait à l'époque à cette séance de
rentrée filet de l'armée italienne
détient 6 de la louve
oui je dis le petit uniforme et tout ça
vous était aux premières loges
on comprend maintenant pourquoi alors en
47 vous travaillez dans un journal qui
est un petit peu comparable au canard
enchaîné voilà marc aurèle en france est
donc là vous connaissez vous rencontrez
fellini quel chef le caricaturiste et
hadji scarpe l adisq baby qui après j'ai
travaillé avec eux deux grands
scénaristes et sont eux qui
il était un peu plus grand que moi et
ils m'ont invité à faire un peu le petit
[ __ ] sur le scénario il est déjà
scénariste affirmé et il me passait mais
glisser le scénario et j'ajoutais des
lignes de geng
c'est un peu comme woody allen ou diana
il a commencé comme vous c'est à dire y
faisait des gags pour des écrits pour
alberto sordi pour une touche loi qu'il
signe et déjà ah oui j'ai attendu des
années pour bah oui parce que après vous
étiez aux bretons chier les scénarios
quand un scénario était mal foutu on
défile de la schola il va l'arranger
et vous dites moi mon père on était
malade sur votre père était celle énervé
de voir ouais il aurait voulu que
j'étais médecin
heureusement mon frère est devenu
médecin donc ça l'a un peu soulagé oui
mais mais il est malgré tout il y avait
des excusez moi mais il avait déjà vu
des films que vous aviez à oui oui nous
sommes tant aimés
alors non je alors entre 48 et 50 vous
fait vingt scénarii donc c'est beaucoup
et puis après vous écrivez vous effet
décidé moi je savais pas c'est le
fanfaron vous oui fonction d'oeuvre
absolu événements les monstres oui je la
marche sur rome
monsieur j'avais écrit au moins dix
films pour le gaz mans pour le dire ici
pour pietrangeli pour 12 rbds et une
fanfare en dépassant alors 64 cette
première mise en scène donc parlons
femmes avec gassman déjà dont qui joue
aujourd'hui dans le dîner donc c'est
vraiment un
c'est lui qui m'a obligé à faire la mise
en scène sa faute si je fais ce métier
qu'elle je voulais seulement écrire mais
c'est lui qui a dit aux producteurs je
voudrais que ce soit a été rédigée dans
le 64 donc c'est mon premier film c'est
avec lui il a eu raison parce que quand
on regarde nous sommes tentés mais il ya
des idées de réalisation qui sont pas
qu'ils sont des vrais si les deux
réalisateurs quand par exemple dans le
restaurant tous éteints et qui sont
seulement éclairées avec la douche comme
ça où le plongeant au début qui qui qui
se termine qu'à la fin du film
c'est des idées de vraiment de domme
d'image c'est pas seulement d'hommes
d'écriture toi tant qu'il a eu raison
gassmann nous aimer je pense que
l'écriture le sait fait aussi l'image
et et les images le faux les écrire donc
je pense que ce soit un seul métier je
comprends pas comment on peut diriger un
film sans l'avoir hic
alors bon pas citer tous vos films parce
qu'on a beaucoup diront les plus du plus
célèbre parce que il se trouve en
cassette donc les gens par les htc
entendu en soixante dix neuf films que
ça vraiment révélé en tous les cas ici
c'est drame de la jalousie oui 74 ans
n'a parlé nous sommes tentés mais 75
affreux sale et méchant film
extraordinaire où vous vous dites c'est
l église qui avait quitté toujours
heureux les pauvres et vous voulez
entrer la crise après les preuves sont
malheureux ils sont méchants et parce
qu'ils sont pauvres
oui et vous montrer la férocité de la
misère et ça c'est un c'est un grand
grand moment aussi passé des choses qui
n'est pas tellement été dit 77 une
journée particulière on en a parlé
les nouveaux monstres 79 la terrasse
avec le doigt dans l'oeil qu'ayant la
nuit de varennes le bal enfin bon pour y
passer là on pourrait passer la soirée
ce qu'on peut dire quand même ettore
scola c'est que c'est toujours des
problèmes de société toujours la grande
histoire officielle et les petites gens
en face quand même ça c'est un peu ça
presque en région dans ces deux thèmes
dominants toujours de maux cinéma c'est
la grande histoire qui passe sur nos
toits sur nos têtes nous prenons pas
partie aux décisions de grains en
politique mais c'est nous qui faisons
les lillois c'est l'homme que le gens du
commun qui vont toujours eu le flair de
l'humanité oui alors vous dites la force
du cinéma italien fut d'avoir le génie
de rire de ce qui aurait pu faire
pleurer
et c'est vrai qu'en france par exemple
quand on voit un film comme la marche
sur rome
en france on sait pas faire ça c'est
qu'on n'arrive pas à traiter ces sujets
là on les traite toujours d'une façon
très sérieuse et c'est vrai que le
cinéma italien est arrivé à faire rire
avec des choses bien plus graves du
cinéma français du cinéma populiste de
le front populaire du vivier l'équipe et
l'équipe est là c'est sur les racines du
réalisme italienne d'emilie par exemple
quelqu'un qui est arrivé à faire rire
enfin disons sourire avec quelque chose
d'épouvantable les plus épouvantables et
c'est toujours cette tradition
finalement alors vous dites
le rire doit être un reer contre quelque
chose sur le rire douanes 60
g il faut un livre qui fait bouger les
choses et on ne peut pas simplement rire
pour se moquer comme ça il faut que le
rire soit positif ou est positive sinon
le rire avec sympathie de quelque chose
on a deux firmes la chose
le bout satirique c'est de deux voies la
vie l'espoir changeait ouais vous êtes
un humanisme croyais au progrès au
programme dit je suis un mélancolique
actif un pessimiste guy ça vous définit
assez bien et aurions une phrase
formidable le type à rome vous en
souvenez de 7 à naples pardon qui ne
souhaitent pas de cette phrase
mackellerie ouais le type qui dit j'ai
tellement fin que ça me donne envie de
rire ah oui oui c'est ça résume tout ce
qu'on vient de dire oui c'est vrai que
si sinon me s'il irait il y à la
nourriture mais au moins qu'il y ait le
rire au cinéma italien aujourd'hui il
n'ya plus ya plus de fellini pas une
hydre céline et visconti des sica
comencini dont 4 alors c'est partout
comme sage parce que aussi l'art la
musique la peinture le cinéma c'est un
peu comme la géographie et à ddv grands
moment de poids et puis il ya des
montagnes mais aussi dans la peinture
des siècles avec des géants de la
peinture puis non la musique dans la
19ème la musique italienne après non jeu
parce que c'est pas si grave que ça
c'est pas un optimisme à tous à tout
prix mais je pense que c'est normal il
faut être convaincu qu sylla piano la
couronne du piano le même allant par
nature plate et la lassitude la plus
dure c'est important il faut couloir il
faut être sincère il faut travailler
avec amour avec avec passion puis les
montagnes si non alors il ya une phrase
de daniel toscan du plantier dans figaro
magazine de samedi qui parle du cinéma
italien et qui a cette phrase tout à
fait mélancolique il dit il en parlant
du cinéma italien il rassembler des
publics populaires et cinéphile réunis
pour le plaisir d'un spectacle qu'on
croyait à tort éternelle c'est vrai que
quand on apprécie les choses on croit
que ça va toujours dur est bon dans tous
les cas en attendant il ya votre film le
dîner on retrouve tout ça on retrouve
tous ces acteurs on retrouve ses fans à
sandrelli qu'on a adoré dans nous sommes
tombés mais oui j'espère que ce soit un
film qui on le sent proche d'un film et
elle est aussi apparue aussi ci
correspond à un certain besoin du
spectateur ce moment je passe dans le
siècle de la communication très facile
d'être totale avec tout le monde dans le
temps réel mais on ne parle plus c'est
une société mur est bien là ils sont
tous là ils sont pas devant la télé sans
restaurants issus famille alors
l'importance d'écouter de parler et je
pense que c'est un besoin de l'homme et
pour ceux comme aide tous comprendre je
pense que les deux films qui sortent
mercredi à le dîner la plage et chaque
fois ces deux endroits où les gens
veulent se retrouver justement menacer
hollywood avec caprio lot de celle votée
mais c'est le même sujet c'est des
endroits où les gens veulent se veulent
se parler en tous les cas merci
j'étais heureux de vous rencontrer et
j'espère que nos amis téléspectateurs
aussi on était heureux de vous voir en
tous les cas ils peuvent les voir le
dîner donc ettore scola avec fanny
ardant giancarlo giannini vittorio
gassman stefania sandrelli marie gillain
et puis et puis d'autres évidemment
merci gerets et bruxelles merci beaucoup
on continue avec notre visite guidée de
l'expo etienne jules marey à la
fondation électricité de france dès 1850
le physiologiste passionné par
l'aérodynamisme réussissait à fixer le
mouvement sur pellicule résultat des
images qui tiennent du mirage agnès
varda et pierrick béquet sont allés
rêver debout magnéto montrer ce que
l'oeil ne voit pas etienne jules marey
figure majeure des sciences du 19e
siècle a consacré sa vie entière à
l'étude du mouvement
il est à l'origine de nombreuses
découvertes qui concerne notamment la
photographie et le cinéma agnès varda
nous fait découvrir les inventions de ce
pionnier de l'image en mouvement c'est
pas l'inventeur du cinématographe ces
avancées oui c'est encore plus beau
c'est dans le grouillement des
inventions de juste avant une invention
mais vous allez voir c'est formidable
il a reconstitué en photo et ensuite en
sculpture les instants de vol d'oiseau
il a reconstitué le mouvement en faisant
une petite une petite lucarne
donc c'est presque le cinéma c'est
presque le cinéma en fait il faut
surtout aller plus vite parce que la
voyez là je vois volée d'oiseaux communs
en fait si le mouvement déjà qu'on aura
dans la caméra vous voyez là bas j'y
voit voler avant de s'intéresser aux
oiseaux etienne jules marey a observé le
vol des insectes il veut voir au ralenti
pour mieux apprécier le mouvement c'est
une machine climatique reconstituant la
force ascensionnel développé par un
insecte pendant son vol
vous imaginez le mec qui a essayé de
reconstituer sa et qu'il reconstitue le
nombre d'heures que la face et à garder
des insectes et à faire des
photographies
le voilà le fameux fusil dans lequel il
mettait la pellicule et qui permettait
de tirer si j'ose dire pour
photographier etienne jelma réinvente la
chronophotographie qui est la
décomposition du mouvement par l'image
en fait ce sont des photographies fred
prises avec vos journaux grave et
ensuite regardé le char gardeccia
regardez quand la caméra est inventé
hilare filmer ses chronos photographie
[Musique]
comment il ça recommence tout le temps
parce qu on a monté en boucle les
quelques images qu'il avait ce chrono
photographier et refile mais en fait
c'est l'invention du dessin animé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très connu ça c'est très coquin
est très charmant ces petites sommes
dans une allée jetons que c'est très
très tout à fait à l'image des films
surréalistes
ça fait penser à man ray à bunuel venez
voir des choses plus étranges qui sont
ces le visage humain
la bouche qui l'a visage qui parle il ya
les images de sa de son visage et de sa
bouche qui dit je vous aime c'est leur
fils maj image par image de jeu
voyez enfin j'ai pas comment dire enfin
voila je vous aime je vous aime je vous
aime
[Musique]
on commence avec la cendrillon de
prokofiev chorégraphié par noureev au
palais garnier jusqu'au 25 avril
noureev modernise radicalement l'héroïne
de perrault les carrosses deviennent
limousine et le prince charmant se
métamorphosant venait du showbiz pour
françois roussillon le conte de fées ne
se transforme pas pour autant en
histoire à dormir debout magnéto
pour être exact l'histoire de cendrillon
fut racontée bien avant que son
narrateur le plus célèbre charles
perrault en face la vedette de ces
femmes content car on trouve trace de
l'orpheline qui a perdu sa pantoufle
neuf siècles avant notre ère en chine en
1986 rudolf noureev comptait sa manière
pour le ballet de l'opéra de paris
cendrillon celles mises en musique par
prokofiev une cendrillon de notre temps
qui rêvait sous les sunlights un destin
de cinéma dans ce conte de fées moderne
la bonne fée devenez producteur de
cinéma un pygmalion de génie qu'il
transforme la souillon angle amoureux
étoiles de l'écran petrika ionesco qui
crée un pur nureyev la scénographie de
cette spectaculaire superproduction qui
se déroule dans les studios d'hollywood
la remonte aujourd'hui au palais garnier
[Musique]
c'est quelque part à travers le cinéma
aussi que les femmes se sont émancipés
le jeune fille rêve évidemment de faire
des carriers si c'est possible au cinéma
encore tente mieux et donc je me suis
quelque parti que ce n'est pas qu'une
histoire d'amour parce que ça sera
quelque part lui enlevait la sève
total se pourvoie simplement une
histoire de réussite générale ça veut
dire
cendrillon réussi son amour avec le
france mais réussit aussi sa vie une
femme moderne maintenant le rêve que ça
l'est aussi en même temps sa vie
[Musique]
prokofiev déjà composé sur les arnaques
en 58 av nostalgie de l'occident tout en
étant par la guerre un aussi et on sent
bien que dans sa musique qui a rien de
réussir ton peu par rapport à ce qui
composait d'habitude on voit qu une
mécanique très énergique très dynamisant
enfin on voit bien
les lumières de la ville on voit bien
tous ces films où il ya des grosses
mécaniques cette évolution comme sable
des années 30 des sonorités qui est qui
existent spectacle avec humour la
cendrillon de noureïev caresse la
nostalgie d'un âge d'or du cinéma ou
charlie chaplin king kong et les
étourdis sentent chorégraphies des busby
boclé enchanté le public
une magie de l'écran à jamais perdue
nous rien fut également marquée par un
des plus grands séducteurs de woods
rudolph valentino auquel il dut sont
pris mon rêve avec comme fait une grande
carrière à hollywood
il n'a fait qu'un film et il s'est
arrêté là donc je me suis dit que
quelque part il doit être révolté et
c'est la seule chose dont il n'a
vraiment pas totalement réussi de sa vie
ça a été redit qu'il aura 14 ans après
sa création la cendrillon de noureïev
pour laquelle la cie liste japonaise ana
et maury à betty malvy est faible le
costume n'a rien perdu de son éclat
pour leur reprise l'étoile fanny quaida
confère une aura de charme et de
mystères à cette héroïne unique qui a su
transformer son rêve en réalité
je reçois maintenant la danseuse étoile
aurélie dupont bonsoir alors j'ai
remarqué que en fait en france il ya
deux dupont dans la danse c'est comme
chez hergé il y en a un avec un thé
c'est vous enfin l'une avec un thé et
avec un des ses patrick alors j'ai envie
de vous dire c'est très joli mais à
notre époque quand on est une femme
qu'elle est jolie elle vous répond en
général c'est réducteur vous concernant
vous êtes vous de vous me dites pas
c'est réducteur
ceci étant c'est vrai que vous n'êtes
pas que jolis alors on vous a en fait
vous explique en a fait un sujet sur sur
carmen de roland petit à l'opéra et puis
bon allez formidable magnifique avance
bien les belles et ou alors on a dit on
va l'inviter voilà alors on va regarder
un petit bout de ce sujet et ensuite on
discutera avec aurélie dupont magnéto
[Musique]
voilà donc c'était aurélie dupont dans
carmen à l'opéra de paris
chorégraphié par roland petit vous êtes
non seulement jolie vous êtes belle
alors on a parlé un peu de vous de votre
vie vous êtes né en 73
votre père était médecin à l'institut
pasteur ni toujours et toujours et vous
dites il se consacrer à 100% à ces
malades et cette dévotion à son travail
que vous lui reprochez sans doute un peu
à l'époque
finalement vous l'avez en vous d'une la
même façon j'ai compris j'ai compris
justement l'intérêt qu'il avait pour son
travail et pour ces malades entre
guillemets bien plus tard parce que je
fais évidemment pas la même carrière
mais c'est le même temps le même la même
notion d tuer les mêmes applications les
concessions tout ça donc maintenant je
le comprends mais à l'époque cette
partie vivre à ces jeunes aux états unis
vous êtes et majorettes
alors ça quand même c'est extraordinaire
de voir ce que vous auriez pu finir
majorettes il en vouliez deux pianistes
c'était une espèce d'obsession chez vous
vous étiez toujours collé sur le piano
comme ça et vos parents ont pas voulu
pourquoi je sais pas je sais pas on en
reparle de temps en temps c'est vrai que
j'ai une passion ma première passion et
l piano j'avais 6 ans j'étais fasciné
par cet instrument je jouais j'étais
vite et fasciné je voulais absolument de
prendre des cours de piano et je
demandais un parent continuellement
acheter ce dont jamais voulu je pense
que connaissant un peu je pense qu'ils
avaient peur que ce soit un petit peu un
une envie subite est passagère et qu'ils
ont préféré justement ne pas ne pas vous
offrir ça eh bien c'est ce qu'ils
savaient pas quelle opiniâtreté
nous avions alors j'ai fait de la danse
qu'on veut comme vos soeurs j'ai
commencé à dix ans et vous êtes présenté
à l'école de l'opéra
après trois mois de danse seulement et
alors là c'est incroyable avait mille
candidate et vous avez dit moins une
quinzaine de prise c'est très compliqué
de rentrée l'école de danse quand tu
quand j'ai commencé j'avais fait très
mode danse en effet donc j'étais assez
assez nul et je suis maintenant donc un
pur produit de l'opéra parce que j'avais
pas de je pense que l'opéra il préfère
parce que souvent les élèves qui
commence mal et petits-enfants qui
commence trop tôt la danse prennent
souvent des défauts on essaie de gommer
après ils préfèrent prendre des gens un
petit peu vierge de tout pour les former
de a à z
et là vous arrêter vous avez été formés
parce que vont complètement mode les
doigts je veux dire des gens vont vous
inculquer des choses très dures et une
psychologie d'une personne de 20 ans va
déjà très difficile et très jeune
discipline de fer c'est vrai qu'il ya un
prof qui vous forcer à monter sur des
pointes avec des semaines des faits j'ai
eu des professeurs un peu difficile je
crois que je ne sais pas si c'était moi
qui étais particulièrement sensibles ou
ou peut-être pas fait complètement pour
cette école mais c'est vrai qu'on ai
fait ma première professeurs
à l'école de danse trouvé que j'avais
passé de force dans les fils que vrai et
ce qui était vrai à l'époque et elle
m'avait acheté des pointes avec une
semaine en faire évidemment je me suis
mis torse sco est moins sûr j'ai passé
mon premier examen avec une entorse et
vous mangez aussi des choses terribles
c'était daoud à 10 ans dans sa laisse et
vers 14-15 ans que j'avais tendance à
être un peu plus un peu plus ronde où la
crise d'adolescence a été un peu
difficile à passer ou là je crois je
mangeais des ordis euros pour cent des
blettes des légumes et le rader et rien
de très excitant
il ya des brimades danser dans ces
écoles en face d'eux des journées on est
c'est une question de jours par rapport
à au laxisme qui avant l'éducation
nationale c'est très difficile choix de
l'école de danse et un peu moi je
compare souvent service militaire ça me
ferait ça quand on a 15 ans on peut à la
limite se comprendre et puis on a fait
on a déjà cinq 5 années d'école de danse
derrière nous donc on touche on touche
au but mais quand on a dix ans déjà de
raisonner comme un adulte c'est très
difficile on se rend bien compte et en
même temps l'assument qu'on n'a pas la
même éducation que les autres que les
autres enfin qu'il ya dix ans font bien
autre chose puisque à 16 ans d'ailleurs
est ce assez difficile et c'est combien
d'arbres également à la même si on n'est
pas comme les autres en même temps c'est
un choix un passion donc c'est un peu
comme un sacerdoce d'une certaine façon
vous étiez évidemment le petit rat qui
veut devenir étoiles c'est poétique je
trouve et à 16 ans 89 et admises au
corps de ballet de l'opéra on l'a déjà
la discipline se relâche un peu elle se
relâche parce qu'on n'a plus quelqu'un
derrière nous on va nous motiver à nous
dicter un petit peu de ce qu'on doit
faire ce il ya une discipline qui est
qui est toujours là et qui est qui est
très présente et le problème le problème
qui se pose c'est qu'on a on se retrouve
seul on doit gérer notre carrière on
doit gérer justement cette discipline
qu'on nous a inculqué pendant six ans le
plein que après trop trop freiné parce
que parce que c'est là où on peut perdre
beaucoup de temps alors avant de trois
ans vous êtes première danseuse en 96
alors là il faut vous m'expliquez parce
que d'abord vous avez été soliste voyez
une hiérarchie quand on rentre encore
doit lancer quoique coryphée par exemple
c'est un mot qui date d'un truc de la
première la première classe vous êtes
kadri stagiaires pendant un an ce cadre
et de carrie stagiaires de dire que vous
êtes remplaçante de tout le corps de
ballet le corps de ballet c'est
l'ensemble est dans ce rapport qui sont
bien souvent derrière les danseurs
étoiles qui sont l'allemand est donc là
vous apprenez
tous les rôles pendant un an c'est assez
terrible comme situation parce que on
peut vous demander cinq minutes avant de
laver des ruelles du rideau de remplacer
technique au pied levé donc ça c'est
difficile ensuite vous devenez kadri
donc vous avez droit de passer des
concours et des concours internes chaque
année pendant une sélection interne qui
est très dur mais c'est à dire sur 30
kadri par exemple il ya deux ou trois
places chaque année ce qui est au dessus
de kadri qu'est-ce qui est la prairie
fait corrie fait c'est ça voilà coryphée
sujet sujet c'est au-dessus de corps il
fait aussi de korité end si j'ai
première danseuse et quand vous êtes
mère danseuse n'avait plus de concours à
passer vous êtes ou non nommé danseur
étoile
voilà hélas hélas en fait que vous
pouvez devenir ou non et toi et voilà
c'est fait ses preuves dans sa vie well
as quand même jusqu à 40 ans l'âge de la
retraite alors vos rencontres ça a été
effectivement le disait roland petit
pina bausch qui était vraiment une
révélation en révélation pour vous que
vous disais pourquoi montreux tu tentes
force laisse faire ton corps accepte toi
comme tu es c'est à dire qu'elle vous a
apporté une certaine liberté mais pinasa
est une rencontre qui a qui m'a
bouleversé en tant que danseuse et en
tant que personne
parce que bien souvent j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer des
chorégraphes contemporains bien souvent
c'est où une rencontre technique est
formidable où une rencontre humaine qui
est formidable et c'est très difficile
où c'est rare en tous les cas de trouver
quelqu'un qui vous apporte les 2 epinal
on va apporter les deux c'est à dire une
technique contemporaine qui est très
difficile et qui mérite autant de
travail que les tunes technique
classique on a on apprend moins bien
moins que la technique classique et avec
un apport est une révélation et parce
qu'il était un peu triste
j'étais déprimé vous fait déprimer
parfaitement et alors là mesdames et
messieurs le 31 décembre 1998 donc après
don quichotte ugal s'approche de vous et
vous annonce que vous êtes étoiles alors
là c'est plus seulement brillé par la
technique c'est vraiment se mettre au
service du chorégraphe
qui faites-vous enfin vous êtes vous
entré entre la première soliste et le
l'étoile qu'est la différence en dehors
du plaisir que ça vous a fait je pense
que quand on est nommé dans ses toiles
moi la différence que ça m'apporte et
c'est juste un titre en plus c'est une
espèce de couronnes contre la tête ce
soir parce que vous réveillez lendemain
vous dansez pas mieux vous avez des
fautes et je suis fier de toi mais vous
êtes une étoile et donc vous avez ce
titre suprême que c'est donc pour effet
l'équipe
moi j'aime beaucoup cette étoile abbaoui
une fille des étoiles c'est génial mais
je pense que l'étoile au sens propre du
terme se révèlent des années après c'est
à dire c'est vrai que j'ai les mêmes
défauts les mêmes qualités j'ai une une
maturité qui ce qui se fait au fur et à
mesure des années j'acquiers une
technique peut être un peu plus un peu
plus subtil et depuis non plus
j'aimerais français il était surtout
mais c'est une responsabilité bien sûr
alors là vous avez un accident tout de
suite après treize ans après problème de
cartilage derrière la rotule et vous
rester six mois alors là vous dites au
début vous êtes déprimés mais que
finalement ça vous a permis de digérer
votre nomination
moi ça m'a fait un bien fou déjà en
règle générale quand je m'arrête de
lancer ça me fait beaucoup de bien
oui ça manque pas tellement j'ai honte
de le dire mais ça me fait du bien
puisque j'ai besoin de me reposer un peu
là il s'est trouvé que ça tombait mal et
ça tombe de toute façon toujours mal et
c6 moment permet justement de d'assumer
ce titre qui est pas évident et puis
quand j'ai été nommé je m'y attendais
pas il ya souvent des prix en danseuse
ou des premiers danseurs qui quelque
part au fond d'eux peut-être l'avouent
pas mais au fond d'eux semble que ce
avec le moment moi je sentais absolument
rien donc j'ai besoin d'un peu de temps
pour pour faire macérer pendant votre
adolescence vous vous étiez un petit peu
vous soeur sorte
dans les boîtes données vrai que vous
avez quand même une vie très très réglée
et aujourd'hui finalement votre vie
quotidienne c'est pas mieux parce que
vous répétez quand même attendait de 12h
à 19h
c'est pas mieux mais en même temps j'ai
le jeu peut vivre un peu si après je
vais sortir si tu veux le week end avant
de partir elle a compensé des soirées de
les brumes ou très bien non mais c'est
vrai que vous dites et entendre la
rédaction voilà la réaction
la direction attend dès qu'on se coucher
à 21h et 23h quand il ya spectacle sans
alcool sans fumée oui mais vous ça
prouve qu'on peut être dansé et vous
dites quand j'ai le trac plutôt qu'un
bain chaud un bol d'eau tiède et je
préfère une nuit blanche et un verre de
vodka
ça c'est pas vrai c'est un article que
j'avais fait pour vsd je crois que je
peux dire est donc l'article était était
pas mal et ils ont rajouté cette petite
phrase qui vient pas de moi j'aimerais
aller votre charisme qui son absence
mais il est vrai que je ne suis pas
contre un bon verre de vin entre amis ou
un bon resto et à la bonne heure est
liée à la bonne heure alors dites moi on
va terminer sur les choses d'un peu plus
people ou m'en voudrez pas mais vous
avez vécu avec deux danseurs de l'opéra
où je dis vous dit j'ai envie de
partager avec quelqu'un qui soit
étranger à tout cela mais c'est
difficile de la télévision je ne sais
pas c'est difficile toujours de me dans
tous les milieux de vivre avec quelqu'un
qui fait mon métier vous et c'est vrai
que quand vous êtes nommé danseur étoile
et vous vivez avec quelqu'un qui est pas
forcément étoiles ça peut mal se passer
ou bien se passer
en l'occurrence moi ça s'est mal passé
mais mais c'est vrai que c'est beau
chercher plutôt quelqu'un en dehors du
milieu de la banquise qui me change la
tête d'accor très bien bas je pense que
je vais voir beaucoup de coutume épisode
moi de vous le dire mais vous allez y à
2 deux femmes deux filles en second
souffle fantastique et hélène grimaud la
pianiste qui est un talent fou tu es
très belle vous vous êtes très bas l'eau
si vous avez beaucoup de talent et les
dieux vous en vraiment enfin des faits
se sont vraiment penchés sur votre
berceau parce que vous alliez la beauté
le talent alors on nettoie là on nettoie
la vie vous êtes étoiles pour le restant
de vos jours tu étoiles
j'aimerais je serai oui on meurt ex
danseuse étoile
oui je serais toi jusqu'à 40 ans à 40
ans me demanderez gentiment adacore
équidés mais je suis on me répond il
mais les étoiles ne meurt pas je voulais
vous faire ce compliment avant de finir
si bas bientôt en tous les cas
merci d'être venus on enchaîne avec
notre coup d'oeil sur le phénomène
capoeira cette danse de haute lutte
initiée par les esclaves voici trois
siècles a forgé la souplesse des hanches
brésilienne health enseigne aujourd'hui
sur tout le bassin francilien et
christophe sand ou est allé se jeter à
l'eau magnéto la caf weather la fois
sport dans ce qu'on appelle aussi d'art
martial les anciens maîtres ils
préfèrent emploi lutte c'est comme un
combat le dic
donc il va voir la tacc l'autre va
utiliser sa défense comme la défense de
la cape wind c'est les esquives c'est
pas bloquer un coup c'est les éviter et
aussitôt contre-attaqué qui nous
connaissent pas la cas pire ils pensent
qu'il fait mes chorégraphies réglées et
c1 mais non c'est tout improvisé le
vainqueur ce n'est pas celle à qui tape
au crest tomber l'autre au vainqueur
celui là qu'arrive meilleur exprimer ses
mouvements et qui arrive à voir vraiment
une échange avec nous
[Musique]
à 40 ans passés béja flore est un des
grands maîtres parisien de la capoeira
formé dès l'âge de 13 ans b ja flore
enseigne en france cette danse
ancestrale depuis 1986 dans la grande
tradition brésilienne avec chansons leur
caste l'origine de la capoeira c'est la
culture africaine
donc elle est conçue par une culture
afro brésilienne son histoire elle date
de xvième siècle les démarré pendant
l'esclavagé au brésil et des esclaves
bontoux de la côte nouveau de l'afrique
qui s'étaient envoyé là bas comme
esclaves et ses peuples
les différents nations africaines qui
ont créé la carte et spirituel physique
ethnique la capoeira est aujourd'hui
discipline devient sérieusement tendance
résultats en france le nombre de cours
et d'élèves ne cessent de se multiplier
la dépouille de son roulé elle n'est pas
la mode parce que ce n'est pas une mode
c'est une à linars ne peut pas être la
mode elle est simplement elle s'installe
tout gentiment délicatement comme elle à
s'installer au brésil au moins 2,3 au
suis sûr que il va voir beaucoup de
pratiquants de cap ghir en france comme
en europe entier
n'importe quel individu qui à son
minimum de qualité physique il va
pouvoir s'adapter à l'entraînement eelv
a réussi à prendre le nécessaire pour
pouvoir s'amuser
qu'il soit un enfant de trois ans de
quatre ans soit un adulte de 60 en face
en disant ça dépend de lui et de ce
qu'il veut rencontrer dans cet art
qu'est ce qu'il veut comme comme un
musulman
alors vous aussi entrer en transe
découvrez l'univers de la capoeira
car la culture c'est aussi la poésie
d'un corps qui s'abandonne à la danse
[Applaudissements]
je reçois maintenant pierre assouline
pour la parution de sa biographie
d'henri cartier bresson aux éditions
plon
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez reçus
c'était l'année dernière pour la cliente
qui était votre premier roman et on est
heureux de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
pour une nouvelle biographie alors je
donne un petit peu votre part votre
palmarès mais votre cv
vous êtes directeur de rédaction de lire
vous êtes producteur animateur de
première édition sur france culture ce
qui veut dire que vous vous levez le
matin de super tout parce que c'est de
cette année c'est ça non oui c'est fait
de vainqueur mais c'est pas plus mal
ouais donc vous coucher à minuit vous
lever à 5 heures c'est ça oui on sait
beaucoup de choses comme ça arrivent ça
vous fait beaucoup de choses
alors quand jean marie cavada vous a
demandé de faire cette émission tous les
matins sur france culture
vous avez dit mais je suis peut-être pas
l'homme de la situation et vous êtes ici
chez vous alors vous vous aviez mais
comment vous le savez et vous allez y
c'est une très bonne foi ce jeudi vous
avez la qualité qu'il faut l'inquiétude
wish qui devrait toucher juste c'est
vrai moi je suis plutôt inquiet parce
que pas seulement pour une émission de
radio ou de télévision mais même pour ce
que je crois savoir faire c'est à dire
des objets graphiques que ce réveil est
mou 9e n'est à faire à chaque fois j'ai
la même inquiétude qui fait que je pense
que je vais pas y arriver parce que vos
accès bien parce que c'est trop
difficile à la sortie c'est parce que
vous êtes inquiet alors justement vous
avez fait pas mal de deux biographies et
dassault il à gaston gallimard il ya
jean jardin cannes bel air
albert-londres s'ils n'ont rg moïse
camondo avec le dernier des calmes on
entend beaucoup parler et puis un récit
qui est un peu une forme de récit c'est
du chien combelles le fleuve combelles
le roman dont on parle est la cliente et
pilleurs des entretiens aussi donc d'un
livre avec blondin des enquêtes les
nouveaux convertis l'épuration
intellectuelle vous avez fait vous et 46
ans ah oui vous ai fait dix-huit bouquin
oui enfin je vous racontais mais bon ça
me paraît pas extraordinaire parce que
bon j'ai commencé peut-être un peu tôt
et puis j'adore ça donc ce n'est pas ce
qu'on me disait tout à l'heure en
parlant de vous finiriez à l'académie
française je sais pas mais je peux vous
dire où j'ai commencé chez philippe
tesson ah ouais j'ai commencé au
quotidien de paris j'ai comme tout le
monde
presque tout le monde c'est vrai quoi
combats sont quotidiennes paris et le
nombre de juristes qui doivent quelque
chose d'efficace ont ils sont légion
mais il a confiance en vous l'aï dit va
aller à l'académie française
bon alors aujourd'hui on parle de
cartier bresson donc chez plon alors le
xxème siècle siècle de l'image bresson
cartier bresson est né en 1908 et donc
vous le baptise deloeuil du siècle ce
qui effectivement une très bonne formule
qui n'est pas de moi avant qu'ils
étaient deux ans dominique bauby
ah oui c'est un article dans paris match
qu'il avait consacré à cartier bresson
et de mobilité un ami et quand j'ai
retrouvé cet article ça m'a ému a vu lui
sa fin et j'ai fait un clin d'oeil aux
clandestins comme ça qu'elle de dire oui
alors évidemment la vie de cartier
bresson c'est un peu l'histoire d'un
regard porté sur le porter sur le siècle
alors vous êtes plutôt doué parce qu'il
refuse de parler enfin cartier bresson
c'est bien connu refuse de s'exprimer de
parler de son oeuvre
il refuse d'être pris en photo est ce
qui pour un photographe est quand même
assez gonflé alors vous l'avez rencontré
la première fois en 94 c'est ça oui je
les ai rencontrés parce que je voulais
faire une interview pour le pont lire le
magazine et il refusait depuis toujours
puisqu'il refuse d une interview il
n'aime pas les rencontrer tout ça enfin
ce genre de rencontre et puis finalement
il a accepté un jour et on a sympathisé
on a passé une demi-journée ensemble on
a on a bu un verre de rouge après dans
un bistrot du quartier
et puis et puis m'a écrit puis je
l'avais écrit puis j'ai téléphoné et
puis on s'est revus pour prendre le thé
pour se promener et puis on est devenu
amis leurs copains et puis ensuite amis
et au fil des années se fait quand même
six sept ans au fil des années je
n'arrêtais pas de lui dire mais tu sais
un jour j'aurai vraiment faire un livre
sur toi ils me disent vraiment mais
vraiment je ne veux pas parce que ça
m'intéresse pas et puis me raconter sa
vie et puis l'un dans l'autre c'est
devenu masque vous êtes dit c'est que la
morale de la vie de cartier bresson
c'est la désobéissance alors j'ai fait
pareil j'ai désobéi vous aussi j'ai fait
ce qu'ils voulaient pas que j'y suis
enfin il m'a toujours dit dans la vie il
faut désobéir
voilà effectivement c'est une leçon de
sa vie sa désobéissance permanente à sa
famille à ses maîtres et à la société
c'est un anarchiste dans l'âme et donc
un jour je lui dis ben écoute j'ai une
surprise pour toi je t'ai désobéi
gg j'ai écrit un livre marie alors il ya
une phrase que vous ne vous pas une
phase ii sur ans qui dit il est
incroyable que la perspective d'avoir un
biographe n'est fait renoncer personnes
à avoir une vie et vous vous dites parce
qu'un si terrible chute elle la
perspective d'avoir un jour un biographe
n'aurait jamais fait renoncer henri
cartier bresson à avoir une vie mais il
est trop fort mais c'est sa passion dans
la vie c'est la vie c'est la vie
jour on disait qu'il avait qui l'animé
palais qu'on parle de lui il aime pas
les photos il n'aime pas les
rétrospectives ils appellent ça des
obsèques prématuré alors sa vie
maintenant famille famille de
manufacturiers dans le coton c'est assez
riche des grands bourgeois des grands
bourgeois et aussi le début du siècle il
est donc en 1908 et cartier-bresson très
vite très tôt vers l'âge de 13 14 ans
finalement n'est pas un bon écolier
s'intéresse pas du tout à ça il quitte
le lycée avant le bas qui ne passe pas
son bac il n'a qu'une passion dans la
vie c'est la peinture et le dessin de
l'art sa mère l'emmène aux bouffes
presque tous les jours sont de
véritables écoles c'est le louvre et
puis finalement bon il réussit à part
les amitiés de ses parents à
s'introduire donne dans l'ombre de
jacques emile blanche
le peintre et portraitiste et il devient
un petit peu son assistant informel et
puis surtout il intègre l'académie lot
qui est une grande économie de la cuire
la parole à la fin le public présent
alors voilà et d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
ça on sent quand enfin vous vous
souvenez très bien mais quand on voit
les photos de cartier bresson
c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il ya sept
regard parce que par exemple les photos
de cartes les pressions n'ont jamais été
recadré par exemple c'est à dire que les
clones refusé voilà avec quand il
faisait la photo elle était déjà il a
cadré avec son oeil est ensuite avait
pas derrière un tigre un cadre à 20 ans
il était fait il rêver hein il a eu un
compas dans l'oeil grâce à ce qu'il a
pris celle hot
il a une conception géométrique de
l'espace sont des lignes des
perspectives
il n'en est jamais sortie de ces photos
sont les photos d'un artiste pourquoi
parce que c'est un artiste avant tout
pour lui la photo c'est un média
l'appareil photo n'a aucune importance
puisque ma pierre je vous presse un peu
mais comme il a cadré le réseau les
péchés donc après donc il voit dans les
années 20 les surréalistes il fréquente
breton crevel max jacob qui d'autre le
nord fini aragon première photo en côte
d'ivoire lors d'un voyage en afrique
oui il a tout plaqué à cause d'une femme
qui avait dix ans de plus que lui il
était fou amoureux d'elle un amour
impossible a été mariée et donc il
plaque tout à 22 23 ans un grand
romantique une sorte de vins très rabal
bien dans l'esprit et il part au
cameroun et il va chasser le faut et il
vit un an là-bas
avec les produits tu as hâte sa chasse
et il s'achète un appareil photo à ses
anciens il fait ses premières photos
avec quand ils rentrent d'afrique
il passe par marseille et là il achète
un appareil tout nouveau pour l'époque
qui est le leica 24,36 petit appareil
qui à l'époque ressemble à un jouet
aujourd'hui c'est un bijou
à l'époque j'étais un jouet et il fait
ses premières véritables photos de
reportage est tout de suite ce sont des
chefs-d'oeuvre voit l'arrivée annoncée
c'est à son père en compagnie de max
ernst et il traîne alors moi pas tout
raconter montparnasse le mexique où il
reste un an
new york en 35 où il ya une première
exposition et là il décide pour la
première fois c'est en 32 d'arrêter la
photo cr que trois fois de suite en 32
ans 36 ans 70 il a décidé d'arrêter la
photo est là il va être documentariste à
ce moment là il fait documentariste et
il part d'abord aux états unis dans le
sillage de paul strand pour apprendre le
document le documentaire ensuite bon il
revient en france il est il ya
photographe pour ce soir besoin de
l'aragon et puis à la guerre d'espagne
hélas comme seul homme de gauche et qui
sera toute sa vie un militant de gauche
la fibre militante le reprend et il part
en espagne du côté républicain
naturellement pour faire d'un film de
propagande à la gloire des républicains
comme documentariste il ne fait pas de
photos alors que robert capa à son ami
et huit fondateurs d'avec lui l'agent
smackdown
les photos qui fait qu'il n'ya aucune
photo d'un vainqueur d'espagne par
quartier blanc ça il veut devenir après
il veut devenir réalisateur alors il va
voir bunuel il va voir pape ceux qui
refusent parce que nous on n'a pas
besoin de toi comme assistant et renoir
accepte je savais pas du tout c'est vous
et il est l'assistant de trois fils
louis et son chat n'importe lesquels
quand la critique emparée de nos
rebelles avec du jeu le troisième c'est
quoi il a réglé et puis naturellement
j'ai oublié mais les bienvenus non mais
c'est fou parce que c'est vrai qu'il
devient quand même assistant et en plus
il joue pas ce que vous montrez
d'ailleurs dans le livre des photos où
l'on voit dans partie de campagne avec
bruxelles savais pas du tout et leur
premier grand reportage 137
c'est le couronnement du roi
d'angleterre george vi à londres allons
ça c'était un reportage magnifique mais
comme toutes ces photos de jeunesse
d'ailleurs il avait déjà fait beaucoup
et puis à ce moment là arrive la
première grande date dans sa vie
première grande rupture c'est la guerre
la guerre il l'a fait bon il l'a fait
sous les drapeaux il est fait prisonnier
il passe trois ans dans un stalag alors
il était prisonnier dans les vosges le
jour de l'armistice est long
r son appareil photo oui dentaires sont
délicats dans une ferme en disant je le
retrouverai il a retrouvé il l'a
retrouvée mais il passe trois ans quand
même dans les stalags ces expériences
pour lui inoubliable très dur
et comme c'est un last un trade son
tempérament inquiet tout à fait
important c'est un évadé c'est un
frénétique ses positions droite en tête
il ne tient pas en place il ne peut pas
et c'est quelque part et malgré le
danger il s'évade trois fois et la
troisième est la bonne il rejoint dans
144 jean laffon 144 et là il entre dans
la résistance et prisonniers de guerre
évadés et en même temps il fait défaut
alors là il ya toutes les photos alors
il y avait tous les portraits qui sont
célèbres
this matiz claudel brac gandhi juste
avant son assassinat avec la lassitude
sur le visage de gandhi la chine
puisqu'il était là bas avant la victoire
des communistes et pendant la victoire
des communistes ils font de l'agencé
magnum 147 je crois avec eux robert capa
et seymour
il est le premier à entrer en urss après
la mort de staline quand je continue
parce que mon gars fuchs nerfs
giacometti camus bangalore marilyn bas
ils demanderont oui pendant le tournage
des désaxés les misfits raconter
d'histoires où il mêle les quatre
équipes de magna était là bas l'un après
l'autre
et puis lui avais quand il y était il
avait sympathisé au dossier avec marilyn
et un jour ils attendaient il y avait un
repas de tout le tournage et il avait il
entend démarrer linky ne venait pas et
cartier-bresson été ainsi et à côté de
lui à une chaise vide et il avait juste
posé son leica et marlene arrive et
elle va pour s'asseoir la voix de leica
et elle fait mine de se voir poser ses
fesses et elle hésite et cartier-bresson
en envoyant du dyba bénisse et le dessus
elle se lève est l'émanation délicat
lavelli laïque alors le seul qu'il ait
raté c'est de gaulle un oui enfin il
devait se voir et puis son pv sont pas
là ils se sont arrêtés l'un l'autre
c'était quand même les deux géants du
siècle zawiyah alfred stieglitz qui dit
qui raconte une photo devant parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre quand même que ces
photos elle n'est pas par hasard qu'il
attend trois heures dans dans le
blizzard à new york pour pour un flocon
de la fameuse photo fief avenue au
winter c'est à dire que en fait c'est un
il attendait que le mec saute laflaque
pour la fameuse photo etc
donc c'est un type qui s'était pas drôle
tous les jours que je dire ce n'était
pas juste des rendez vous pour aller
faire clic clac devant des stars n'ont
jamais été ça toute façon cartier
bresson cartier bresson c'est un
promeneur c'est un pérégrin c'est un
homme qui a passé sa vie à prendre son
temps de bouger il n'aime pas voyager
mais il aime être à l'étranger
et quand il est quelque part il peut
rester six mois un an deux ans trois ans
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui
selon les reporters sont envoyés tous à
fait différent et quand il fait des
photos même des portraits de commande
pour la il faut pour match pour les plus
grands journaux fauquenoy par exemple il
imitera il mitraille pas il fait pas
cinq ans mobinil fait quelques photos
via la une la photo de marie curie ont
été pierre curie entrée de chez ea
célèbre photo il l'a fait en tout cinq
ou six photos et c'est la première qui
était là il a sonné ils ont ouvert la
porte et il a vu là c'est des
personnages comme des personnages
médiévaux il a été saisi et avoir un de
dire bonjour il a fait une photo et
c'était ça et gt racing alors il a
appuyé 540 mille fois sur la sur la
détente ce qui est beaucoup mais compte
tenu de ce que vous dites ça veut dire
qu'il a fait pas mal de photos parce que
comme il faisait pas la fin il a
commencé à 20,23 lamela 91 91
alors votre livre on est élus avaient
désobéi pour le faire mais quand il l'a
lui qu'est ce qui vous a dit il la lui
il m'a dit d'abord il m'a dit où as tu
trouvé tout ça j'ai été mauvais à teaser
schiste me raconter sa finale à six ans
et demi oui effectivement
et après il m'a dit c'est curieux j'ai
eu le sentiment de lire l'avis d'un
autre
ouais j'ai gagné content il a ajouté une
chose et ça je le rappellerai il me dit
bon eh bien maintenant que tu as écrit
mon portrait je vais enfin pouvoir te
tirer le portrait of a donc voilà vous
êtes immortaliser
alors il connaît la date de sa mort
parce qu'il ya une voyante madame colle
qui lui a qui lui a prédit quand il
était jeune tout ce qui est arrivé plus
tard et tout est arrivé et tout est
arrivé donc je connais la date de sa
mort la tête et les conditions mais je
parie que pour globalteer mais c'est
très étonnant ça aussi alors vous votre
biographie je suis désolé vous avez pas
mal le prendre mais beaucoup moins
intéressant oui que la biographie de ce
dont vous raconter la vie parce que bon
vous êtes amené à kazan 53 vécu je crois
12 ans au maroc puis ensuite j'étais
arrivé à paris puis voilà vous eu une
carrière assez assez bonne d'ailleurs
dans les médias les livres 18 10 on a
parlé tout à l'heure
lire le journal mensuel lire la radio
maintenant et vous dites d'ailleurs vous
le savez bien vous dites la vie d'un
biographe est égale à la somme de ses
biographies dire qu'en faites-vous pour
vous pour connaître votre vivre pour
lire vos biographie que c'est très
simple andré maurois qui était un grand
biographe a écrit ses mémoires qui
n'obtiendrait aucun intérêt en revanche
si vous prenez c'est d'une graphie de
disraeli de byron de shell etc
voulez-vous les ucsa posé et en
filigrane entre les lignes dans les
interstices vous avez sa véritable
biographie souterraines
c'est à dire l'histoire de ses passions
et de ses goûts juge herman autres
justement vous avez dit un écrivain et
crée toujours par rapport à son secret
et alors vous la question qu'on se pose
en la cepalc à passer d'habitude vous
faites des bio de gens qui sont morts et
qui ont tous fricoter pendant la guerre
l'occupation et c'est bon là cette
fois-ci bon cartier bresson conduite
exemplaire en plus entre vitrine clinard
emprise et dans son stalag et il est
toujours vivante banc donc c'est là pour
une fois c'est un peu atypique dans les
biographies de pierre assouline
mais c'est avec généralement vous êtes
attiré par des écrivains de droite
antisémite collaborateur jean jardin
mais entendu lui il était clairement à
vichy rg non vous avez révélé même si on
le savait un peu son appartenance au
mouvement existe simenon alors là dans
votre biographie de simenon vous dit des
trucs absolument incroyable kalima
évidemment oui mais je vous y en a qui
ont également 4 weiler qu'ils étaient
juifs qui était un homme de goût et les
morisques amende aurait moyen de 15
euros
et enfin il ya les deux noms mais bon
lucien combal qui est devenu votre ami
qui était directeur éditeur de
révolution nationale quand même donc qui
sont les moins bien tiré que je conçois
chalet parce que je crois qu'ils ont eu
la même une activité pendant la guerre
mais combelles s'en est jamais remis et
mourir au bord de la seine ce que vous
racontez très bien fleuve combelles et
chalets lui
finalement tout le monde avait oublié et
je réfléchi à ça dans la cliente votre
héros ce pas vous qui il dit qu'il est
sépharade comme vous juive séfarade et
qui dit qu' il est opposé au nombrilisme
de là sur la mémoire juive au
nombrilisme de la shoah alors vous c'est
un problème ça chez vous c'est à dire
qu'à la fois vous en parler tout le
temps mais en même temps on dirait que
donner une certaine l'absolution en
disant ils sont humains finalement ces
gens là n'ont d'abord je ne parle pas de
ces gens là parce que c'est qu'il n'ya
pas un groupe c'est pas un bloc
j'en parle pas comme ça non ce que ce
qui m'énerve c'est le judéo centrisme
c'est à dire de toujours tout juger par
rapport ce que pense telle ou telle
personne ou des juifs hausse qui ne
pensent pas de juge donc c'est pas pour
moi c'est s'agit de vos centrisme c'est
sam cela dit je ne suis pas près de
l'airé de solutions d'abord parce que je
n'ai pas qualité pour le faire
et puis c'est pas du tout le monde dans
mon tempérament non c'est pas si jamais
vous avez tendance à avoir
l'ambiguïté des gens oui ça va vous êtes
très compassionnel parole en baisse il
m'intéresse à redire humain trop humain
et j'avais pas la voix de madame de
staël qui dit comprendre c'est déjà
pardonné
déjà si on va essayer de comprendre ni
fichu on pardonne mais moi ce qui
m'interesse vous avais dit le mot c'est
l'ambiguïté
or l'ambiguïté chez beaucoup de
personnes de personnages personnalité de
l'occupation elle surgit de manière
beaucoup plus forte que dans les
périodes de paix civile
c'est pour ça que l'occupation
m'intéresse c'est parce que l'ambiguïté
des hommes est beaucoup plus prégnant ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure il ya eu un
débat pas si vous l'avez vu avant de
devenir un soldat il ya un débat avec
olivier pichard justement qui disait que
lui bon bah c'est vrai que jusqu'à 42 il
était à wischik vichy s'était pas la
collaboration qu'il était à vichy c'est
un peu un personnage pour vous en
quelque sorte parce que bon après il a
choisi le général de gaulle et dieu sait
s'ils étaient fidèles à de gaulle mais
c'est vrai qu'au départ comme ça il ya
toutes ces hésitations des gens de
gauche
on en a parlé que robert belot des gens
de gauche qui sont retrouvés que lamont
collaborationniste enfin vraiment
hitlérien des ados rios qui venait du pc
du ps en fin de l'époque alors vous
dites d'ailleurs je suis très isolée
dans mon milieu on ne comprend pas
toujours vous avez des amis juifs qui
vous reprochent
oui ben brik et qui comprennent pas des
positions d'axel et j'ai même un ami qui
a refusé de lire la biographie de jean
jardin par principe en me disant moi je
ne peux pas admettre qu'on
consacré un livre avec un point comme ça
sans savoir qui c'était si c'est bon
donc bon ben tant pis pour lui bien joué
les normes c'est une question que j'ai
avec carmouze bdt100 s'était promis de
vous poser je suis content de voir poser
de façon le sujet là aujourd'hui est
tout autre puisque je répète donc le
titre du livre c'est cartier bresson là
et du siec donc par pierre assouline
chez plon merci d'être d'être venu on
enchaîne avec notre portrait de
l'écrivain marc edouard nabe qui publie
kamikaze le quatrième volume de son
volumineux mais lumineuse journal intime
sur les moeurs germanopratine eric matin
et elle est assistée au régal de la
vermine magnéto saint-germain brûle-t-il
plus cruel que mathieu gallet plus
incisif que les frères goncourt flirtant
avec paul léautaud
la dernière livraison de marc edouard
nabe porte bien son nom kamikaze un raid
précis violent n'épargnant rien ni
personne
et curieusement rédempteur pour son
auteur il ya des enjeux d il ya plein de
la contradiction elle et elle est alors
l apparente en fait la vérité d'un net
et dans ce qu'il fait donc je pense que
même nom
3/10 angélisme il est dans ce que je
fais ça paraît très très dur et très
violent et insupportable quand on ouvre
le livre on est en face de morceaux du
présent mais ces morceaux du présent son
date d'une dizaine d'années et c'est ça
qui fait un choc je crois et pour moi
c'est du vieux présent mais c'est quand
même les angles nabe chronophage
graphomane a le génie de [ __ ] un grand
coup de pied dans la frontière récit
social littérature pour lui tout
s'imbrique peinture musique sexe
mondanités vie familiale ou l'écriture
comme hygiène de vie n'est pas j'ai même
l'impression que ça s'écrit sans moi
comme une machine qui tourne ainsi que
quand je me lève le matin ou le soir
avant de me coucher ou ou dans la
journée ou où partout dans le métro et
dans les toilettes ou soulager dans des
chambres dans des zones et que j'ai
vraiment que je sens qu'il faut que je
j'exerce cette gymnastique là est bien
jeune âge a fait je relis pas portrait
aphorismes adoubement détestation nappe
fait cracher sa plume avec la précision
d'un entomologiste et la cruauté d'un
gengis khan des lettres
c'est à la fois désespéré parfois
désespérant jamais mièvre toujours
enflammé les jeunes et les vieux cons
ils sont sacrifiés les vieux démons
céline blois par noyade sanctifie ce
journal n'est pas du tout une
prospective c'est pas du tout une jeep
en train d'essayer d'analyser mes
d'ailleurs pas assez d'ailleurs souvent
mes propres pensées mes sentiments et on
s'est dit c'est moi qui réagit face au
monde
c'est pour moi plus important de parler
des autres et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
fais il suffit de regarder d'alex vous
voyez avec une fois les numéros
correspondent à 250 page d'index avec
des centaines et des centaines de noms
go
seul
g
toujours une entreprise je ne
vraiment des ordres religieux c'est très
très monacale on peut dire travail mais
ouvert sur la vie voilà ça peut-être
qu'il est en chacun son salut voila moi
je suis plus dire chacun pense à lui
[Musique]
on commence avec atom egoyan justement
pour la sortie aujourd'hui en salles du
voyage de felicia 1 fry leur haletant
comme anne hitchcock un face à face
entre une frêle âmes au coeur tendre et
un serial-killer amateurs de chair
fraîche
elisabeth quin a vu la belle et la bête
magnetto wheels
[Musique]
batoumi deux ans au cours
et si chaque cliché
[Musique]
ce boys a été si heureuse tu serais dit
[Applaudissements]
game no 2 et r c'est formidable quand
même d'être dans ce rôle comme ça où
justement je fais des choses qui m'ont
fait peur c'est je dire cette femme
j'ai peur tous les jours de cette femme
de lettres nouveau loué of the finger
turquie weezer en 3h05 parquet de rennes
non non non non non everyone is this is
[Musique]
it
aux lakers et ma nourriture est ce qu
est un peu normal je suis heureux dit il
sans passage au middle east room est
délicat s'y attendait on parle parle de
la mer et du rôle de la merde mais
c'est le mal ah si le mal était que
française n'aurait pas été aussi
horrible peut-être c'est le mal et
universel malheureusement ces normes
universelles c'est sur la mer et
est un personnage universel qui tarde à
être maman
il ya je reçois maintenant le comédien
michel serrault pour la sortie en salles
du monde de marty michel serrault
bonsoir bonsoir très heureux de vous
avoir pour trois raisons d'abord parce
que vous êtes rats à la télévision oui
mais je viens moi je vous quitte pas
parce que je vois tous les jours alors
voyez là aussi c'était la deuxième
raison c'est que vous êtes jeu c'est un
téléspectateur assidu et j'étais pas
content parce que la mode j'aime bien ça
mais on vous à vous un peu écourtée
l'année prochaine normalement ça sera
l'émission durera toute l'année comme je
crierai vous me direz valable vous
écrirez au patron de la chaîne face à
lyon donc
vous êtes toujours le bienvenu ici
d'autant plus aujourd'hui que c'est
votre anniversaire donc je vous dis bon
anniversaire et vous êtes au courant de
tout de tout
alors est ce que vous dites l'avenir non
encore on va être à venir à bout bas je
pourrais dire que des bonnes choses par
le monde de marty de dénis bardiau donc
avec johnatan de mur j'ai sorti mercredi
alors je vais vous dire franchement
l'histoire bon vous dans le film vous
êtes atteint de la maladie d'alzheimer
le petit là le cancer je me suis dit ça
va être franchement jusqu'à leur pack
très gaulois laloë suis dit bon voilà
et force est de reconnaître avec plaisir
que je suis sorti de là enthousiasmé les
larmes aux yeux d'abord enthousiasmé
c'est un vrai hymne à la vie le mot est
un peu un peu bête mais c'est ça mais
pour papa et voilà et je suis sorti de
là le coeur le coeur gonflé de ça m'a
fait du bien et depuis je suis devenu le
meilleur agent de publicité de ce film
et je vous le dis à vous chères amies et
chers ennemis c'est vraiment un film qui
au début c'est un peu aride le sujet
mais pas c'est pas du tout excuser moi
le mot ce pas du tout chien c'est
pendant tout le film
on s'ennuie pas vous vous êtes on va en
parler vous êtes exceptionnel le petit
de murs génial alors je vais dire le
pitch
oui donc marty martin alors l'appel
marty il a dix ans il est hospitalisé
il a le cancer il vadrouille dans
l'hôpital voilà et un jour il ouvre une
porte comme ça il en trouve une porte il
tombe sur vous des rangs antoine b ans
atteint de la maladie d et meurt
paralysé muet et donc pendant tout le
film d'ailleurs vous exprimer on va en
parler envoie fin ce qui est assez
étonnant et marty adoptent beran ce
vieux malade il adopte si ca devien sont
jouées d'ailleurs il l'appelle immobile
man ce qui est assez rigolo et
finalement bas ils finissent par
s'adapter l'un à l'autre et à devenir
amis et à sa portée des choses
mutuellement dans va regarder un petit
extrait et puis on en parle
magnéto
je connais ce bruit
je connaissais dessus du wat coup
beaucop qu'est-ce que j'ai l'âme de ces
mots comme c'est sa mère ça le petit
voyou oubliez vous échapper un jeu ne se
passera pas comme ça allait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le monde de marty donc des demies
bardiau avec évidemment michel serrault
et john hutton de mur j'ai alors bon on
va pas dire où se situe la cène parce
que sinon on va déflorer le scénario 1
martin ne traite pas ne vous traite pas
enfin de traite pas aberrant comme un
malade et en fait c'est ça qui est le
plus étonnant que vous avez eu
finalement c'est le sel le charmer et le
génie des enfants c'est que pour lui
cette bombe
c'était évident c'est pas grave je veux
dire que moi dans la vie ça m'est arrivé
d'aller voir des amis de même des
parents quelquefois dans d état
désespéré
on ne sait plus très bien comment faire
j'ai plus pâtir et le gaucher n'a pas ça
c'est l'innocence il devient sont deux
copains et ils vont cheminer ensemble
pendant quelques mois
et puis bon on voit bien d'ailleurs
quand là quand la femme de bilan via le
ménage elle tricote dernier une première
scène qui est génial c'est quand il ya
l'argent sur la télé oui il ya la femme
qui dort vous vous êtes la réveiller
pourrez pas vous exprimer et le gosse il
prend l'argent sur la télé pouvait pas
réagir et avant de partir les coupes la
tvq et me voilà c'est ce que je veux
dire à nos amis c'est que c'est s'est
jamais misérabiliste sait jamais si
c'est toujours beaucoup d'humour
beaucoup de voix je fais attention par
exemple pour jouer le rôle je voulais
pas qu'ils se soient leurs moyens et ses
combats y parle pas il était très
handicapé mais je veux dire que le
luminaire et quand il s'exprime dans
cette voix off dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure je veux dire on dit bon bah
voilà il prend soin épiler pas il n'est
pas amorti quoi il se défend alors
ensemble
marty et berlin ont construit un monde
où est ce que c'est cette chambre
c'est le monde de chambre que ce film a
l'air un peu d'une fable ya pas de
réalisme vraiment on va pas on voit pas
les médecins trop on voit on va le
traitement et ses terres c'est la
rencontre de ce vieux bonhomme avec ce
gosse à la quête extraordinaire
alors évidemment ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que c'est un
film plein d'espoir écoutez c'est une
femme sur le fait qu'il n'est pas
inutile de vivre et que presque mort on
peut être encore utile quoi voilà c'est
ça en fait c'est ça qui donne la pêche
quand on voit les actes c'est ça c'est
ça
en fait j'ai dit oui ce pour faire le
film du 10 mai c'est assez
extraordinaire ça on ne peut être utile
jusqu'au bout dans les conditions les
plus pénibles mais plus incroyables mais
on peut faire servir être utile encore à
quelque chose et à quelques
et alors ce qu'il m'a dit ce qui masque
j'ai des idées un peu bizarroïdes
mais ce qui m'amuse beaucoup c'est que
le vieux bonhomme et le gosse ne sont
pas au courant du parcours qu'ils font
ils ne savent pas de résultats de l'an
amitié un intérêt or le résultat de
l'amitié c'est que le logos va vivre
peut-être un peu grâce aux vieux et lui
le le vieux va disparaître mais heureux
d'avoir d'avoir connu cette avance alors
vous vont geler dit en commençant c'est
une vraie performance d'acteur parce que
dans ce film vous dites je me suis mis
en état de médium c'est un peu quand je
m'amusais à endormir les gens au service
militaire
c'est vrai que quand vous étiez à dijon
je sais tout de vous c'était pas la
guerre alors c'est pas la guerre mais la
ville précise à mettre dedans
oui c'est vrai quoi faire et le soir et
le soir on avait des longues soirées et
je dis qu'est-ce que je vous entends pas
ce que j'ai mais j'ai toujours aimé ça
les fakirs les indices et vie il n'ya
pas des mecs qui veulent venir avait
toujours des dégâts qui se croient
projet dix mois en mois tu meures
dormira pas la bêta londres et là vous
exprimer vraiment formidable comme comme
performance d'acteur tout simplement
avec un battement de cils sans un mot
puisque évidemment vous ne pouvez vous
pouvez pas parler
ce qu'on peut dire si vous existez
autant dans ce film que zaza napoli dans
la cage aux folles quoi alors que c'est
un débordement de mots hélas ensemble
sans rien dire vous existez autant mais
c'est à dire au directeur sa phénomène
on sait pas trop ce que c'est en parlant
de moi les skis et extraordinaire je
pense pas à la présence des acteurs par
exemple au théâtre c'est plus facile
parce que vous êtes en chair et en os et
on vous voit donc on s'étonnerait pas de
voir un acteur qui joue toute une pièce
muet serait là on pourrait ne pas
envoyer des ondes
il pourrait participer ils pourraient au
cinéma c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
je pense aussi que totalement convaincu
de ce qu on joue on peut encore avec
très peu de choses faire passer des
sorties ça passe ça passe ça passe très
bien
alors vous continuez quand même à
prendre des risques parce que ce film
quand on veut on a dû vous la portez le
scénario quand même il faut avoir envie
de ses pagaies pour faire ça faut être
fait gonfler en plus de réalisateurs
n'ai pas fait grand-chose il avait eu un
premier prix un festival
de courts métrages ilonise un parent
bessan bardiau oui bon après il avait
fait un court métrage chapet peinard
d'ailleurs avec jaffré le coscénariste
et pas fait grand chose non plus ils
n'ont plus battu pour que le film puisse
se faire c'est à dire qu'à un moment
vous êtes discret parce qu'évidemment
quand on lit ça que personne n'y croit
beaucoup
ça va pas non y a pas d'histoire de ses
pas une c'est pas une image mais il n'y
a pas de coups de cul si vous voulez il
ya pas de moins de piste ho là là il n'y
a pas on peut pas se réfugier d'aller
dans tout ça alors cessez pas
encourageant pour des gens qui veulent
faire de l'argent volé des mecs qui
savent à 1 ça peut en faire l'un des
enfants du marais rire les enfants du
marais quand ce film est sorti la presse
pas toute la presse mais une grande
partie de la presse avait dit qu'est ce
que c'est ce film c'est réactionnaire cp
tennis avait besoin calixte et
pétainiste et ça a été un énorme succès
donc moi je pense qu'un film comme ça on
sait jamais c'est ça qui me rappelle
quand j'étais un peu en colère parce que
systématiquement je suis tombé ça a été
un peu difficile
ouais monter ce sont des gens qui eux se
faisait racontée par des collaborateurs
parce que il ya très peu de gens qui
prennent des responsabilités et qui il
faut le dire c'est pas grave mais faut
le dire donc utilisé puis vous verrez
alors le petit acteur la johnattan de
murs gk 11 ans non plus il a commencé à
8 ans est aussi un symbole un acteur ces
quelques incendies la glace à saint-omer
d'ailleurs et comédien cascadeur c'est
sa mère joué dans des séries télé dont
il nous a élevés danon et ses
grands-parents vais certainement du
circuit vous qu'est ce que vous faisiez
11 ans au même âge
on sent que ce que j'étais un onze ans
jeté dans la rue ouais j'étais dans la
rue oui alors j'allais au cirque parce
que j'ai toujours aimé le cirque
j'habitais la banlieue et le spectateur
sur les fortifs la cdo préserver oui
j'avais chez un copain des 10es de des
fortifications le boulevard d'algérie et
moi un but de la porte brunet alors faut
pas qu'on nous emmerdent en été un petit
voyou un peu petit chef
bon c'était pas les loubards c'était des
petits loubards de bd des années des
années nous piquer des trucs quand même
et tout ça moi je voulais voler c'est
une époque ont volé pour manger des
fruits pour entrer à 3-4 dans une
boulangerie on disait maintenant le
patron robert
il faut donner les plombs mais puis les
machins et al ahmar est alors déjà à
l'époque vous hésitiez coentrepr est ou
clown fait-il toujours ce côté non mais
c'est vrai
tous disent côté gay mystique pieux
blagueur vous hésitiez entre prêtres et
clown c'est vrai non oui c'est vrai
alors j'ai pas j'ai quelqu'un m'a dit ça
ya récemment encore il m'a dit
finalement que l'iphone et depuis je
n'ai pas encore de je prêche pas encore
non mais vous êtes croyants et voilà
vous avez été renvoyé alors du conflent
la du petit séminaire en voyons on a
fait comprendre gentiment que que je
t'ai peut-être plus doué pour le cirque
peut-être où les planches que pour pour
leur l'homélie ou pour annuler témoin
les curés dans les films de mots qui
sait tout mais alors devant ses
fanfaronnades et votre esprit comme ça
un peu petits chefs qu'on a du mal à
quand on voit maintenant vous êtes
devenu tellement un radieux on imagine
mal le petit jeu n'était pas méchant
l'avant non non on arrêtait les jeux
dans le métro ou des descentes les gens
nous ont demandé des cigarettes ont été
un peu de tout mais on n'a jamais frappé
alors la journée quelqu'un qui vous a
dit bah écoute tu devrais aller au
conservatoire de la rue blanche l âge de
16 ans vous avez vous avez voilà j'ai
commencé comme ça j'ai entendu dont il a
en même temps vous avez continué à aller
aller au cirque parce qu'en fait vous
étiez vous dit que c'est mon premier
spectacle la première fois que j'ai ri
où j'étais éblouie par l'est par la
présence des clones qui reste pas moins
à nu un mystère j'adore les mystères
tout ce que je comprends pas évidemment
j'adore que ne peut pas faire autrement
va pas se fâcher parce qu'on comprend
pas ton j'adore mais c'est vrai alors
c'était pas que vous faisait des petits
spectacles comme ça parallèlement au
conservatoire vous peignez des affiches
à la main visible dans les magasins je
fais j'ai voulu changer
oui les gens pensent que poirée chéreau
par exemple on venait de chez moi ou
c'est plutôt en venaient aux gens et moi
on a préparé le conservatoire et ouais
on voulait être des acteurs des acteurs
classiques on l'a rejetée
et alors on est obligé de faire notre
d'ouvrir notre boutique alors vous été
virés justement de la rue blanche après
deux ans votre premier contrat c'est
dans 146 pour détourner en allemagne et
en france avec jean marie serreau côté
un grand ami et quelqu'un qui avait
beaucoup de talent qu'est le papa de
coline serreau
ah bon je savais pas que j'étais
thériault a eu alors 2 est revenue deux
heures avez-vous c'est pourquoi vous
avez été viré du conservateur au bout de
deux ans soit parce que je venais pas ou
je
je ne travaillais pas suffisamment
aujourd'hui y est ou n'est jamais été
fâché est maudit on me disait comment on
peut me le dire encore aller faire ça
ailleurs on ne nous intéresse pas or
jugé bon on va voir un goût trop tard on
verra bien parce que je crois que pour
être comédien il faut d'abord il faut
pas aller dans une boutique
il faut regarder un peu partout et j'ai
eu la chance bien avec les jeunes de me
balader un peu partout oui j'ai été j'ai
pas été chez jouve est parce qu il y
avait plus de cours à l'époque mais j'ai
vu je vais quand même jouer la comédie
mais j'allais chez dulin par exemple je
mets beaucoup je travaillais avec les
bars il ya quelqu'un qui a eu un peu une
expérience similaire à la vôtre de la
rue comme ça c'est luchini s'est
beaucoup promené dans la rue dans son
quartier près de la goutte d'or là bas
il a appris comme vous dans les
boutiques en regardant les gens disent
trop vous savez ce qu'on fait les uns et
les autres les médias c'est parce qu'on
ya des grandes oreilles et des yeux est
ce que ça quand on vous dit est ce que
vous avez travaillé pour préparer le
film we dernier à 70 ans qui travaillent
l'autre quelqu'un qui m'a dit mme alors
vous répéter chez vous parce que j'étais
sur le plateau jeudi avec qlikview pote
avec ma glace vélo vous pour viser
d'abord je peux pas a profité que la
glace en plus je sais pas toujours qu'il
va me donner la réplique donc chasse pas
sur le terrain cela va de soi lorsque
j'ai appris en préparant cette interview
en fait c'est que vous aviez été je
passerai été son élève mais vous aviez
connu etienne decroux qu'est vous dit
enquêter le un professeur de mime
mais c était le professeur de marchaux
oui c'est ça oui oui bien vous dit en
parlant de lui ce grand silencieux
auquel les élèves doivent tant
d'éloquence c'est con comme un
magnifique
il avait aussi une formule qui nous
faisait rire à l'époque parce que on
passait beaucoup disent les acteurs
faisaient des stages
il fallait prendre l'expression
corporelle le mime et à l'autriche sa
devise c'était un homme nu sur une scène
nue et les luttes et des spectacles où
il avait juste un petit truc devant
capitale mais autrement ils étaient tous
nuls et il faisait la machine à vapeur
une fois la création du monde c'est le
summum du mime c'est une joie lors il ne
nous a pas les pires on ne saurait faire
une machine à cause d'une soupirail
enfin vous pouvez tout faire par mr vais
gérer plus qu'honnête
ça a des limites mais j'ai pas me voir
au été l'élève aussi de jeu le paraguay
du coup c'est un crew celui qui n'a pas
fait de l'expression corporelle
il a tort parce que c'est bien les
acteurs font pas cette danse
d'expression corporelle yeux ils sont
passés ils nous apprennent pas la
musique
moi je n'ai pas appris tout ça j'avais
un petit peu un petit peu mais pas
beaucoup mais je pense que on peut pas
apprendre vraiment à jouer la comédie
il faut être curieux mais il faut
apprendre un truc comme ça alors donc le
film de dénis bardiau je répète c'est le
monde demartis sort mercredi ne vous
laissez pas rebuter par le pitch allez-y
voilà un mois j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir n'y a pas de raison voilà alors
vos projets dont il ya le mot qui vous
le faites là elle dans le mode qui j'ai
vu moquer ya pas longtemps il est en
pourparlers
j'avais eu un coup de téléphone ya six
mois le film m'est pas encore remonté et
je lui dis alors tu pense à moi
écoutez vous embêter mais ça va se faire
et c'est dur mais j'adore attention sur
c'est bien sûr donc ça c'est la soutane
turquoise avec emmanuelle béart donc il
doit se monter le libertas assez tourné
alors là c'est fait sur le 22 mars
perez fanny ardant et alors là lyon
balle c'est gabriel aghion qui avait
fait ce film que but tellement de succès
[ __ ] douce c'est certain alors là je
joue à ce jeu un cardinal
alors voyez vous allez vous allez voir
je suis pas docteur pas terrible mais
comme cardinal et pour porter la soutane
rouge et les acteurs justement de
bertrand blier irak toute une pléiade
repasse à ça tout le monde attend ça y
est on est on est quand même temps de 5
oui ils seraient obligés de nous mettre
par ordre alphabétique qui fait que moi
avec mon
ce héros je suis à la fin de la fiche de
tout ça il faut passer par là alors peut
pas pour finir vous restez avec nous
pour le débat c'est parce que vous vous
souvenez notre croissance
c'est pourquoi la souffrance bah oui
parce que je suis petit je ne peux dire
qu'une pêche nettement revues sur la
plage du ruhl c'est les derniers
justement vous faites forcément on a
peur des feux vous avez dit une fois à
l'époque d'assassins s'était mal passé à
cannes
non très bien avant et vous avez dit
franchement vous me voyez arrêté avant
de mourir on enchaîne avec le reste
hideshi la lodéom comment à la veille de
l'an 2000 rebondir sur les ressorts de
la tragédie antique sans la jouer à
l'identique
c'est la question que pose cette orestie
son cortège de meurtres en série
faudrait carbou et a trouvé sa odieux
mais divin magnéto j'ai dit c'est quand
il ya mort d'homme c'est un genre qui se
développe et il y à peu près 25 siècles
c'est une langue qui est complexe et
dont eschyle est le premier représentant
faut que je raconte toute l'histoire de
l'égorger sur son corps vivant tu l'a
préféré à mon père meurt atteignent 4
158 ans avant jésus-christ et celle à 67
ans il remporte le premier prix du
concours tragique avec sa trilogie
l'orestie le restiez composaient
d'agamemnon les choéphores et les
euménides complexe brutale politiques
religieuses et poétique
la tragédie grecque aborde les thèmes de
la justice du droit et de l'amour fou
vingt-cinq siècles plus tard eschyle
reste actuel l'orestie et l'histoire de
la malédiction d'une famille qui s'étend
sur plusieurs générations et qui va
trouver sa conclusion à la fin de la
trilogie fait le lédat gardienne de mon
palais la parole s'est conformée à mon
absence par l'une et l'autre était trop
longue
le roi agamemnon revient de 3 après une
guerre de dix ans sa femme l'attend pour
le tuer sa femme quitta ministre je veux
être honorée comme un homme
non qu'on m'a du titane est retombe à
son tour sous les coups de son fils au
reste qui vient là tuez vous été nourris
je veux vieillit un des côtés tu veux
vivre avec moi après avoir tué mon père
c'est le destin monfils qu'il faut ont
accusé c'est une vraie histoire de
famille mélangez avec cette chose
mythologique avec les dieux et toute
cette écriture si on tue votre père
votre soeur votre votre mère et bien il
faut partir à l assaut du meurtrier même
si c'est quelqu'un de votre famille le
thème ''la de la vengeance sans fin la
vendetta on pourrait un peu rapprochées
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'à l'époque bien
sûr c'était des individus qui se venger
sans fin et aujourd'hui sont des peuples
qu'ils se vengent sans fin par toi frère
fidel je vais retrouver le respect qu à
la force et au droit de ce produit sans
d'un s'unir pour ma 6t la difficulté de
notre travail sur la tragédie c'est de
garder le plus possible en soit 7,7
force incandescente qui est à l'oeuvre
qui agite ses personnages et de ne pas
là j'étais trop à l'extérieur la
peinture du monde à bord d'une tragédie
immédiatement les acteurs se mettent en
posture tragique je parle pas que
physiquement mais dans la voix font du
vérisme il fonde la voie et on a lutté
contre ça de manière permanente et même
encore aujourd'hui tous les soirs celle
chose principale contre laquelle on
lutte à tout prix
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le plateau les acteurs
avancent vertigineusement la mise en
scène dépouillée de georges lavaudant
fait entendre la parole d'eschyle dans
une grande austérité sans sentiments ni
psychologie les voix résonne sur le
sable blanc la tragédie grecque devient
limpide
[Musique]
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu